THE CASE CHANGED
TO CINCINNATI.
STANTON AND HARDING GO,
MM-HMM, WE DON'T
NEED LINCOLN ANYMORE.
BUT LINCOLN DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
ABOUT ANY OF THIS [bleep].
HE WOULD JUST KEEP RESEARCHING
AND RESEARCHING.
OH, YEAH, BUP-BUP-BUP-BUP.
I'VE BEEN JUST GOING ALONG
WITH MY OWN FUN.
HE WOULD WRITE.
HE WOULD BE LIKE,
AM I INVOLVED IN THIS CASE
OR WHAT?
FINALLY, HE FOUND OUT
THAT THE CASE HAD BEEN MOVED
TO CINCINNATI,
AND HE WAS LIKE,
[bleep]!
I'VE GOTTA GO TO CINCINNATI!
SO, HE WENT.
LINCOLN WENT UP TO THE HOTEL
WHERE ALL THE LAWYERS WERE,
AND STANTON SAW LINCOLN
COMING HERE--COMING UP.
STANTON WENT TO HARDING,
OH, MY GOD,
THIS GUY IS A LANKY,
GAWKY, AWKWARD, APE-LEGGED,
APE-L--ARMED MAN.
THIS GUY IS WEIRD.
THIS GUY IS LIKE AN APE.
HE'S GOT APE ARMS.
HE'S GOT, LIKE,
APE, AWKWARD ARMS.
THIS GUY IS, LIKE, AN APE,
AWKWARD GUY.
THIS GUY IS AN APE!
AWK--AWKT--"AWKSWARD"!
HE'S LIKE AN APE-MAN.
THIS GUY IS LIKE AN APE,
AWKWARD MAN.